(fast-forwarded voice squeaks)
Good morning, Hank. It's Thursday, January
18th.
Yes!
If you're wondering why I'm doing my Happy
Dance, it's because I lost three pounds this
week! I'm only twelve pounds away from being
a light-heavyweight according to the International
Boxing Federation. Yes!
Unfortunately, I am also doing my sad dance.
So I may have to extend my deadline by a couple
of days which is particularly humiliating
considering I shared it in public on our video
blog, but I think I will definitely be done
by Wednesday. Definitely by Wednesday! Definitely
by Wednesday! Definitely by Wednesday! Next
Friday by the very latest.
Sometimes when I take a morning off from writing,
I like to go outside, walk through the park,
and play this game. The game is called Who's
Outside on the Upper West Side of Manhattan.
(singing)
Nanny, nanny, rich kid; nanny, nanny, rich
kid; nanny, nanny, rich kid; funny dog!